I mean I talk about this in one of the
chapters of my books you know
specifically about
um
online dating how to use it more
effectively and when and how it doesn't
work so we'll go through this two minute
clip and then we'll talk about it
afterwards but just sort of give you
some frame this is just a random on Tick
Tock that I pulled and she's scrolling
through her dating app and essentially
reacting to what she's seeing now I said
in that chapter that women are generally
speaking for the most part I'm going to
swipe right or left based on your first
picture so watch your behavior and then
watch what happens if she becomes
interested in the first picture and
Scrolls down to see what the next steps
are so just pay attention to this Dave
why why are you doing this no
Chris
no
Ty's the truck driver
nope
dude is automatically disqualified based
on him yeah well he hasn't got pronouns
in there that's just something I
wouldn't recommend yeah attractive women
don't don't date guys oh is this your
best photo
is that is that mandatory with Bumble by
the way do you have to put in pronouns
because I've noticed the last two have
had them it's not I'm not sure I've been
banned from Bumble for so long that I
just don't deal with them anymore I mean
I mean if you could get away with it my
recommendation would be like get slash
[ __ ] uh but bummer doesn't like
shirtless it's ridiculous
no it's like left that
um oh that's a fish nope
Sam he's new here with his tie-dye shirt
nope yeah girls hate fish photos guys I
I tell a lot of you guys that DM me that
grosses them out
and also you got a 40 year old guy
with a [ __ ] neckbeard wearing like a
tight 19 year old like tie-dye sort of
t-shirt Bob Marley poster Che Guevara
backpack yeah you know what I mean
oh this is just a horrible picture like
you're in what maybe three or four
percent of the entire real estate that
you have in that photograph it's almost
impossible and look at the back like the
backdrop but yeah cables there it looks
like he's in a barber shop he's in a
Mexican barber shop that's what they
look like oh is that what that is that's
what my barber shop looks like oh that's
hair on the ground yeah you're right
yeah I think that's air okay I thought
he was at a gym posting a selfie I don't
know but listen over her uh that'd be
better
is that a hair
absolutely not disgusting
Ace cute dog but Jeffrey Dahmer glasses
no next
Nick not bad but CEO at Cash
CEO okay she doesn't like that for some
reason weird bye a lot of guys to their
CEOs and that means they're just not
really doing much
yeah
I mean it's because women know that
there's this boss girl narrative and
most of the boss girls are like you know
CEO you know Karen's dog walking
business or something like that it's
like and they know for a fact she's
making like 35 000 a year yeah like I've
Incorporated the US and I'm legally a
CEO but like I don't ever say that
because I'm making like no money you
know sorry
Albert no why are you so angry you're at
a waterfall this should be a nice moment
smile in your pictures guys like figure
out how to look happy and interesting
and you know content with your life the
last thing a woman wants to do is invite
a miserable prick another day right
what okay you're adventurous could be
fun
uh no
I feel it hahaha
how is this your best photo no
what did she just say there how is this
your best photo right it's like this is
your competition guys like if you're not
using good photography and I explicitly
talk about that in the chapter of my
book how to use proper photography what
kind of photographs to put up if you're
not using good photography the first
thing she's thinking is how is this your
best photograph like this is what you
look like because she knows that she's
putting out her best photograph right oh
oh Terence
you look very surprised
I don't get it
no
your name's Midnight's first range
Hazmat next
Alex same name as me
David can look like my uncle
hmm
do not use filters dudes you're you're a
man you're not a chick don't use bunny
nose bunny ears doggy nose filters stop
doing that stupid [ __ ] you can touch up
your photos learn like the saturation
contrast like coloring all that stuff
but yeah filters Brian no Anthony no
Daniel no
oh Andres
Jason okay not bad not bad
511 likes volleyball
nope so she liked the photographs scroll
down for more and she turned him away
because he's 511. I've said this before
guys I think 14.9 percent of the North
American population is over six foot and
a lot of women have this like demand for
six foot two and the average uh amount
of guys in North America that are over
six foot two is something like four
percent they are delusional like swiping
left on a guy that she's that she finds
attractive and then disqualifying
because of his height
hmm if you're 5 10 or above just put six
foot and then you can wear boots I'm
five eleven I put six
um I'm in the metric system here 180
centimeters that's like the equivalent
of six foot in the English system I'm
fine and the truth of the matter is is
women can't even accurately judge height
like they've tested this before as long
as you're taller than her like I think
the average height for chicks is like
probably somewhere between five four and
five five or something like that I mean
as long as you're taller than her like
generously taller than her like 511
versus 5'5 you're gonna Tower over her
right so it's not gonna matter so yeah
you can round it up if you want no oh
Ronnie no Fabio what Fabio with the
[ __ ] tits like that's not a good look
if you're gonna take your shirt off in
your main picture make sure you should
be looking like a model
and Sam mccar nope Chris nope
Gabriel nope
uh no
no no oh okay let's see firefighter she
Scrolls down let's see what she says
five nine oh he doesn't know what kind
of relationship he wants but yet he
wants kids one day I'm like so would you
say she's Epiphany face post wall like
30 35 Maybe 40.
right it says dating in your 30s so
she's obviously let's call it mid 30s I
mean she's looking for something
long-term so they do get picky or as
they get older too yeah massively
massively okay how old are you 36 now
most guys don't give thought to those
tags that you put on your profile yeah
and you should nope all right so
your take guys can I point out one thing
real quick I actually sat next to a girl
on a flight one time and it was delayed
and on the tarmac on the tarmac she was
on Bumble and I noticed that she swiped
right or left pretty much immediately it
was mostly left left left left there'd
be like every now and then an immediate
right but if she's something caught her
interest she would go into the details
she would scroll through she would look
at all the pictures she'd uh if it's
connected to Instagram go to Instagram
and she would deliberate for a while
before uh swiping on that right so guys
just keep in mind the kind of that's I
think this girl is indicative too of how
they go about it it's left is immediate
if it's right she will dive in and do
further investigation so fill out your
profile use all the functionality you
can on it verify it connect it to
Instagram if you can I've been banned on
all of them so I can't verify or connect
to Instagram and you get other
objections like why aren't you verified
like oh people keep thinking I'm fake
let's get on a phone call show you I'm
not um so you overcome that objection
but that's how women that's pretty
indicative of how women use dating apps
wow
yeah I mean almost all those guys
profiles sucked
um she wasn't wrong on a lot of them
because I mean pictures with sunglasses
uh too close to your face one guy
looking angry you know I mean using the
puppies for bait but
obviously part of her her whole you know
thing here is delusion and dating and
30s and obviously it's and you guys hit
the nail in the head you know as women
get older their standards go off they
don't go down their standards go up as
their options become smaller which is
just crazy that happens but
um yeah most guys have no idea how to
structure a dating app
a lot of guys that think dating apps are
usually start a waste of time it's just
because they don't know how to use them
they don't know how to structure them
correctly
um
I've said this to you said this I've
said this Jared I said this I've said
this to guys that have come and asked me
for
um help with dating apps if you are not
willing to invest your time and money
into a legitimate photo shoot you should
just stay off the dating apps and you're
not gonna have because you're just not
going to have any chance whatsoever and
that's that's the problem with a lot of
guys like a lot of guys think because
they don't get matches they're just like
ugly or they're whatever for the most
part
women a aren't seeing you in B like
you're not setting your profile up the
right way where you can actually get
attention and she can be attracted uh
the height thing
what what Bumble is doing and what these
dating apps do is they are they are
obviously
female marketed towards even though the
dating app split even though 60 of or
out of the user 60 percent are men and
40 are women everything is still geared
towards women keeping women safe like
they're they'll flag certain language
that you use in your messages
um you know they'll encourage you to put
pronouns in your bio astrological signs
do you want kids someday what kind of
relationship are you looking for so a
lot of guys will do that because like oh
like if I'm just really honest and I
just really upfront and I'm I go along
with this female narrative I'm gonna get
matches and get attention and it's just
a complete opposite like I think they've
done studies where
there was one particular that came up to
mind I can't remember what it was where
they had the same pictures really
attractive dude I don't know they use
like a model or something like that and
the bot they had no bio versus bio and
the results were the exact same
so it's absolutely a visual app pictures
are the number one most important thing
most guys what they think is cool women
don't find it cool
uh the fish that's why they failed yeah
like the fish or like this dude with the
chainsaw like that kind of girl that
you're getting the creeper out yeah like
the kind of girl you're gonna get that's
going to swipe right on that is probably
like the single mom with four kids and
has some trees that she needs like some
dead trees in her backyard that need to
get cut down like that's it you're not
gonna get anybody that looks attractive
or something like that hey guys I really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out